c'est simple le seuil est ce sens une
décision a été construit en 2008 par le
conseil d'administration de
l'association d'éducation populaire de
sainte thérèse sur la présidence du
maire joseph aller sans nous sommes très
fiers très très fier du csm donc le
centre international de séjour de
martinique
parce que il possède donc les quatre
handicaps dans le réseau c'est assez
rare en france
nous sommes donc maintenant 22 à avoir
obtenu le label tourisme et handicap au
même titre nous sommes le seul réseau en
france à avoir quatorze établissements
ayant obtenu l'écolabel européen qui est
délivrée par l'afnor
nous avons des valeurs les valeurs elle
s'appelle par exemple la non lucrativité
les valeurs ça va être le partage la
rencontre nous sommes très attachés à
donc le rs la responsabilité sociale
d'entreprise et la protection de
l'environnement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]